we spent a lot of time thinking about
things about things yeah in terms of
making him a real character and giving
emotional sounds ridiculous emotional
complexity and but it shows and the way
he yeah yeah and he does things you know
what sort of like
yeah the perplexity yeah
you can release the stabbing of the yeah
no that's one of the most emotional
moments in there yeah you'd like if on
paper you'd be like um I don't know is
that right well that wasn't gonna work
and that was we agreed like uh how is it
gonna work so it's one of those which
we'd like to do is like to take a risk
in terms of like you have no idea if
it's gonna walk and it could be the
cheesiest there's a rubber hand uh you
know stab to the wall why should you
give a but